[Música]
hablamos de salud de aquí en directo
américa ya está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz
tierra ya fin de semana vamos a hablar
de los transplantes de animales a
humanos una técnica que en las últimas
semanas ha tenido varios ejemplos de
éxito mar pues esa técnica se llama seno
trasplante que significa precisamente
eso no hubo transplantar un órgano de un
animal a un humano últimamente hemos
escuchado por ejemplo cómo se
transplantó un corazón de cerdo a un
hombre y esto sucede básicamente porque
estos cerdos han sido modificados
genéticamente para que puedan tener
compatibilidad con el cuerpo humano que
se les hace por un lado se les inactiva
una biomolécula que tienen todos los
mamíferos menos los primates incluidos
los humanos y por otro lado se les
incluye se les da se les añade digamos
seis genes más también de los humanos al
genoma de los cerdos para que
precisamente estos órganos puedan ser
compatibles una de las científicas que
en septiembre lo que hizo fue realizar
un trasplante de unos riñones de cerdo a
un cuerpo humano que tenía muerte
cerebral explicaba el proceso también
del trasplante de esta manera
de inicio a final lo que hicimos fue
seguir paso a paso exactamente lo que
realizamos diariamente los transplantes
de humano a humano y la transplantation
muy buena queremos ser realmente capaces
de copiar ese paso a paso y demostrar
que podemos hacer un xenotrasplante
exactamente de la misma manera y
demostrar la seguridad y la factibilidad
en este contexto
suena muy sencillo como lo explica ella
pero en verdad hay años y años de
investigación y también de errores
fallidos detrás que últimamente
precisamente pues han coronado con este
ejemplo del trasplante de un corazón
porcino a un hombre vivo a un hombre que
necesitaba un trasplante así es marc
también hubo polémica en este caso
porque este señor que le transplantaron
el corazón pues estuvo involucrado en
una pelea años atrás parece que dejó en
silla de ruedas a la persona que atacó
entonces por una polémica los médicos
decían que éticamente pues tenían que
simplemente salvarle la vida al paciente
pero porque se considera una buena
noticia que se hagan posibles estos
transplantes más pues básicamente porque
todas las vidas cuentan también
probablemente la de la de este paciente
y lo que hacen falta son órganos la
organiza mundial de la salud calcula que
los transplantes que se realizan en el
mundo solo son un 10 por ciento de los
que en realidad deberían hacerse no de
los que realmente los pacientes
necesitan por ejemplo sólo en estados
unidos- vemos que en 2020 se realizaron
sólo un cuarto de todos los transplantes
de riñón que se necesitaban en ese año
en todo el país en general también con
los demás órganos también vemos que la
tendencia suele ser esa lo que hay más
órganos que se necesitan de los que
realmente están disponibles y es
precisamente por eso también que la
comunidad científica celebra que esta
alternativa empiece a presentarse como
una alternativa viable a
todo lo que el mundo quiere es no estar
limitado simplemente por el suministro
de órganos humanos para trasplantes
varios órganos se pueden tratar y se
pueden usar así de un animal
euronews
podrán llegar a comercializarse casi
como un medicamento que se entrega bajo
demanda
y eso es cierto cambiaremos el rostro de
lo que es posible para las personas que
todavía esperan años para un trasplante
del corazón hirsch
marc también la ciencia dice que los
cerdos se parecen mucho a nosotros en
muchos aspectos y entonces le quiero
preguntar si los órganos de ese animal
son realmente una alternativa viable
pues parece que sí sobre todo con estas
modificaciones genéticas porque el
tamaño de los órganos de una cerdo puede
parecerse más o menos al tamaño de los
órganos humanos pero recordemos que
igual todo esto está en una fase muy
incipiente falta todavía algo de
infraestructura falta todavía
investigación pero sobre todo falta
resolver también un dilema ético es
decir es está bien matar a un animal
para salvar unas vidas humanas sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que los cerdos
aunque los tengamos como unos animales
pues que sirven para la comida son casi
tan inteligentes lo más incluso que los
perros para hacernos una idea hablemos
de los riñones por ejemplo para hacer
una idea de cuánto sacrificio
significaría esto de los riñones en
estados unidos- en un año se donaron
aproximadamente 23 mil riñones en eeuu
eso significa que se hicieron 23 mil
transplantes la mayoría de esos con
donantes vivos pero acordemos que además
como cada persona puede vivir con uno
solo de los riñones entonces así es como
funciona y luego también están los
donantes fallecidos que es decir las
personas que fallecieron y que se les
pudo aprovechar los órganos si ellos
habían dado el consentimiento por contra
se necesitan 63 mil riñones cada año
para que no haya una lista de espera
haciendo las matemáticas un poco que hay
alrededor de eso significa que se tienen
que sacrificar 20 mil cerdos cada año en
eeuu solo para salvar a estos estas
personas que necesitan estos riñones hay
varias voces en este debate no por un
lado hay los que dicen que eso lo que se
defiende es que se puede asegurar una
buena vida a los animales y que sólo un
cerdo puede salvar muchas vidas humanas
y hay a los que consideran una
aberración ética completamente
cultivarlos no para este beneficio
humano además también recordemos que hay
otras alternativas no hay se puede
incentivar la donación por ejemplo en
colombia en españa en argentina todo el
mundo es un donante de órganos en el
momento de su muerte si no ha
especificado lo contrario en vida y
sobre todo pues también hay raúl las
personas que temen que un sistema de
donación basado en el altruismo no en
que tú voluntariamente decides donar sus
órganos se convierta en un negocio en el
que los que tengan dinero para comprar
estos órganos crecidos en animales
puedan sobrevivir y los que no tengan
dinero pues no podrán sobrevivir igual
donar marc porque cuando uno se muere ya
no haces nada con el corazón con la
córnea con el riñón pues estos órganos
que se pueden donar para que una persona
tenga una vida mejor después de que uno
se muera y no sólo una no porque una
persona puede salvar la vida de muchas
otras personas completamente de acuerdo
a marc muchísimas gracias vemos el lunes
con más salud aquí en directo américa
vamos a pasar con estos segundo